بالعوده الان الى التطورات السياسيه
المتعلقه بالصفقه المحتمله معنا الان من
الناصره الدكتور محمود يزبك الاكاديمي
والخبير في الشؤون الاسرائيليه نرحب بك
دكتور يزبك في تقديرك ما الذي يدفع
نتنياهو اليوم للاقرار بوجود خلافات مع
واشنطن ما دللت ذلك وما الاته في
تقديرك نعم يعني واضح انه هنالك في الايام
الاخيره كلما اقتربنا من ساعه يعني
الحقيقه بالنسبه للصفقه والوصول الى اتفاق
مع الجانب الفلسطيني كلما يعني ازدادت
الخلافات في داخل الحكومه الاسرائيليه
وخاصه بين نتنياهو واليمين المتطرف
الاسرائيلي الذي يهدده كل يوم ف قضيه
داخليه اسرائيليه والان ما ما يفعله
نتنياهو دائما حينما يكون في مازق داخلي
يحاول تصدير الازمه الداخليه الى الخارج
وفي هذه الايام طبعا العنوان الاهم لتصدير
الازمه الداخليه الى الخارج هو امريكا و
بايدن بالذات وخاصه يعني عشيه قدوم بلينكن
الى اسرائيل في الايام القرير القادمه
فهنا العمليه هي عمليه هروب الى الخارج
بدل ان يحاول ان يحل الازمه الداخليه التي
يعانيها يعاني منها من مواقف اليمين
المتطرف الاسرائيلي وهذا يعني عمليه
تحضيريه حينما ياتي في الايام ال القادمه
بلينكن الى اسرائيل ويبدا في الضغط
والحديث حول امكانيات الحل المست دكتور
يزبك هل الولايات المتحده ورئيس
بايدن قادره الولايات المتحده على الضغط
على نتنياهو في هذه المرحله في ضوء ما
اشرت اليه من خلافات على المستوى الداخلي
في
اسرائيل نعم هو طبعا الولايات المتحده اذا
كان لديها اراده حقيقيه في هذه القضيه في
قضيه الحرب والسلام وتريد حقيقه ان تنهي
يعني ولو مرحليا الصراع العربي الفلسطيني
وخاصه في قضيه غزه هي تستطيع ان تفعل ذلك
اذا لديها الاراده لانه يعني اسرائيل منذ
اليوم الاول من يوم 7 اكتوبر هي لم تستطع
ان ترد شلت اسرائيل شللا كاملا وكانت
بحاجه ل الرئيس بايدن لياتي الى اسرائيل
ومن ثم ياتي خمس مرات الوزير بلينكن وكانه
يحتضن اسرائيل ولو لولا هذا الا الاحتضان
الكل يعرف انه كان هنالك انهيارا داخليا
كاملا في اسرائيل ولذلك يعني الرئيس بايدن
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه طبعا لديها
امكانيات كبيره جدا للضغط على اسرائيل ان
ارادت ذلك وكيف تريد ذلك انا باعتقادي انه
يجب ان يكون ضغط على الولايات المتحده من
اطراف عربيه واسلاميه يعني 58 دوله عربيه
واسلاميه لا تستطيع ان تفعل شيء مع
الولايات المتحده وهذا على الرغم انه
لديها مصادر قوه كبيره لهذه الدول العربيه
والاسلاميه لتضغط على الولايات المتحده ان
ارادت هذه الولايات المتحده لتقوم بالضغط
على اسرائيل لكن قضيه حتى الان هي قضيه
يعني المصالح الخارجيه وامكانيه الضغط
الداخلي في الولايات المتحده على الرئيس
بايدن ليقوم بالضغط على اسرائيل بدون
ضغوطات من الطرف الامريكا على اسرائيل
سيبقى نتنياهو يشعر مرتاحا ويتهم هذا
ويتهم ذاك بحسب هذه د يواجه المشكله و
قراءتكم ل المشهد وهذه التصريحات وهذا
الحراك على المستوى الخارجي او حتى
الداخلي مدى القرب او البعد من اتمام صفقه
جديه تتعلق بوقف العدوان في غزه او بعمليه
تبادل
محتمله نعم استاذ يعني القضيه الاساسيه
هنا في اسرائيل انه الحرب اخذت تراوح
مكانها لا امكانيه هنالك لتوسيع دائره
الحرب او لتغيير مسار الحرب هذا يعني واضح
تقريبا لكل المجتمع الاسرائيلي مرحله
الانتقام الاسرائيليه انتقمت اسرائيل كما
تشاء ولم يكن هنالك احدا يوقف هذا شعور
الانتقام الاسرائيلي ولكن بعد اربعه شهور
ودخولنا الى الشهر الخامس وا الان يعني
يتحدثون عن نقل الحرب من من خان يونس الى
رفح ما معنى ذلك معنى ذلك انه كل الوعود
اللي وعدتها وعدت القياده العسكريه
الاسرائيليه للجمهور الاسرائيلي بانها
فشلت فشلت لانه قالوا في البدايه قياده
حماس موجوده في مستشفى الشفاء فشلوا قالوا
قياده حماس موجوده في خانون
وفي وفشلوا قالوا انه المخطوفين موجوده
هنا وهناك ولا شيء هناك فشلوا والمجتمع
الاسرائيلي يراقب هذا الفشل الان اذا
نقلوا المعركه الى رفح معنى ذلك انه كل
الاستراتيجيه الاسرائيليه هي استراتيجيه
ساقطه منذ اليوم الاول ولذلك هذا الضغط من
ناحيه الفشل العسكري ليس فقط فشل 7 اكتوبر
و خلال الاربع اشهر الاخيره كله عمليه
فاشله الا الضمار والتدمير والقتل النساء
والاط اال يعني والمجتمع يراقب ذلك ويرى
انه في هنالك فشل اسرائيلي كبيرم ذ اصوات
اخرى دكتور يزبك يعني ومراقبون تحدثوا بان
المستفيد من اطاله امد هذه الحرب هو
نتنياهو بحد ذاته فكيف له اذا كان مستفيدا
من اطاله امد الحرب كيف له ان
ينهيها نعم هو حقيقه يستفيد سياسيا في
المرحله الحاليه ولكن الضغط المجتمعي كلما
يعني مر يوم على الحرب دون انجاز دون د
تقديم اي انجاز امام المجتمع الاسرائيلي
هذا يصبح في النهايه ضغطا عليه هو فيعني
في تناقض كبير بين ما يريده وما يستطيع
الحصول عليه وموقف المجتمع الاسرائيلي
يعني هذه الثلاث مركبات مع بعض البعض هي
التي تؤدي الى نتنياهو انه يتصرف مثل ما
رايناه يعني بخنوع امام اليمين الاسرائيلي
من ناحيه ومن ناحيه اخرى في يوم اخر ترينه
يقول انا مستعد ان افكك الحكومه فقط من
اجل اخراج الاسرى و الاسرائيليين ذلك هو
حقيقه يعني في موقف صعب جدا لم يكرر بعد
ولكن ساعه الحقيقه تقترب يعني كل يوم
تقترب اكثر وعليه ان يتخذ القرار وانا
اعتقد انه القرار سيكون باتجاه عقد صفقه
مع الفلس مع مع حماس وليس شيء اخر لانه لو
انه في له انجازات في هذه الحرب يستطيع ان
يعرضها على الشارع الاسرائيلي غير جذه
الاطفال الفلسطينيين لكان استفاد حقيقه
ولكن كل يمر في الصحافه الاسرائيليه ترنا
انه يتحدثون عن فشل هذا الزعيم وكيف يريد
نتنياهو ان ينهي تاريخه السياسي في
اسرائيل هذه على ما يعتقد الكل انه هي اخر
يعني دوره له في في الحكومه يريد ان
ينهيها كبطل والبطل الوحيد الذي ممكن ان
يحلم به هو الذي اعاد الاصر الاسرائيليين
الى ذويهم الى عائلاتهم السالمين وهنا
المشكله الاساسيه هنالك من لا يرغب بذلك
مثل اليمين المتطرف ولكن غالبيه المجتمع
باعتقاده والسياسيين يؤيدون هذا وهذا هو
عامل الضغط الاكبر على نتنياهو شك الدكتور
محمود يزبك الاكاديمي والخبير في الشؤون
الاسرائيليه كنت معنا من الناصره شكرا
جزيلا لك